Peter we haven't had a chance to talk
about Super Bowl 53 even though it was
the lowest-scoring Super Bowl ever
there's still plenty of meat on that
bone I'm curious your big-picture
thoughts on the Patriots sixth
championship in the way they pulled it
off shutting down a team that had scored
54 points eleven weeks earlier in week
11 against the Chiefs holding them to
only three in the game that matters most
I think there could not have been a
better performance in a better four
quarters for the legacy of the best team
of most of our lifetimes and that is
that the Patriots have never won never
in a Super Bowl want to game the way the
Steelers won in the 70s are the Bears
one of the 80s and that is they never
want to gain by a dominating punishing
defensive performance now this was in a
nine sack you know hold them to six
rushing yards game you know there were
times in this game where the Rams did a
few things but to hold the highest
scoring team in the NFC to three points
and those three points coming on a
53-yard or 54 yard field goal whatever
it was and to make the Los Angeles Rams
punt for the first eight times they had
the ball that says that this New England
team basically gave the pedigreed coach
the coach was one of the best defensive
coaches in the century of football it
finally gave him the kind of game that I
believe he's always hoped that one of
his teams would play at the highest
level of football and Peter one thing
that impresses me now that we've had
time to really let this digest as your
defense is forcing the Rams to punt punt
punt punt punt punt punt there's got to
be a moment where there's a temptation
to start dialing up some things down the
field because you're getting frustrated
hey we're shutting these guys down we're
confident we can continue to shut them
down
we're not scoring points but they
continue to stick with their plan
because I believe they didn't want to
take the kind of chance that creates an
opening for Aaron Donnell
- blast Tom Brady into the Atlantic
Ocean and and and and I think that was
smart to not give in to that temptation
but it had to have been very tempting to
start trying to open up the offense a
little bit more to try to take advantage
of all these opportunities to score
points when the Patriots just they could
move the ball but they couldn't cash in
I would say that on both sides of the
field Mike I would I'm a little bit
surprised looking back on the game that
both teams didn't take more shots and
you know honestly the Rams had a shot
you saw I just saw the thing on next-gen
stats this morning when I woke up that
Jason McCord II had to travel 19 point 2
yards in a in just a matter of like two
seconds to get to the ball and to get to
Brandon cooks in the back of the endzone
you know and that really that play I've
watched it now ten times that without
any question is jarred cooks fault
you know he has got to make that call
earlier you see that on that play on the
replay you see Brandon cooks his most
reliable most effective receiver okay
and I and even though I love Robert
woods I think in a game like this I am
looking at Brandon cooks who's used to
playing on the very big stage he's going
like this at the 10-yard line and where
in the world is the ball it just took
too long to come out of the arms of
Jared come out of the hand of Jared cook
look he's waving for it he wants it he's
waiting waiting waiting you can't wait
that long you can't make a guy wait that
long and that to me we're looking at two
you know the most the most significant
play of this Super Bowl in my opinion
because that would have made it seven to
three and who knows then what would
happen after that if the Rams go up
seven to three Patriots are shaken up a
little bit they can't move the ball I
wrote at length about what Josh
McDaniels did with ten minutes left in
the fourth quarter
he got the offense together and he said
look we're changing everything about
what we're doing and putting a big
package to keep their base defense on
the field which ended up working great
on the next two series but my whole
point is we have no idea what would what
would have transpired in this game if
that play would have been converted and
I mean we could have a new Super Bowl
champion today but what a play by Jason
McCrory but what a poor play by Jared
golf hey Peter I agree with you
completely in this schematic that they
have on the next-gen stats Twitter
account
it shows how that play busted open how
Devin McCourty got sucked over to the
wrong side of the field by following
Robert Woods could cover Robert yeah and
ran ripe on there were three guys on
woods no one on cooks and you're right
golf held the ball too long and when he
finally threw it he didn't zip it maybe
in one of those situations where golf is
thinking oh crap he's so wide open I
can't blow this instead of just firing
it in there like he would have maybe if
he'd been covered you gotta fire it in
because you got a small window you gotta
got wide open he puts too much air under
it he gives Jason McCourty the chance to
clean up Devin McCourty mess and I'm
right with you on this he had about 19
minutes left in the game after that less
than 19 between 18 and 19
yeah and it's 7 to 3 now the Patriots
have a different mindset when they have
the ball the Rams have a different
mindset on defense they've just had a
kick in the pants they are fired up they
have momentum they may be coming after
Tom Brady more aggressively than they
had all game and one bad move there by
the Patriots offense you setting the
stage for 10 to 3 14 to 3 and maybe the
floodgates open for the Rams in the
final quarter if the Patriots can't get
things going and they never get to the
point where as you pointed out in
football morning in America they
reconfigured the offense on the fly to
make things happen when they needed to
in the fourth quarter when it was 3 to 3
everything's different when it's 7 to 3
and and that was the play of the game we
don't know what would have happened next
but that kept the Rams out of the end
zone it forced them to take a field goal
and it changed the philosophy the
strategy the psychology everything of
the game going for
or did not get that touchdown not only
that Mike when you talk about sort of
the philosophy and and what and what the
feel was of this game the feel was as we
are sitting there in the press box you
and I and I'm watching this game
I keep thinking series after series
after series what must be going on in
the head of jarrod golf now Jarrod Golf
to me has the mentality of a cornerback
he's very good at letting the most
recent past go but my question is play
after play after play series after
series after series with nothing
happening on this great great offense
and so much of it is your fault you have
to start asking yourself this question
what would happen if Jarrod Gulf had had
this incredible success this bomb
against this impenetrable Patriots
defense what would have happened would
he have been emboldened would he have
played better in the last say quarter of
this game uh I can't answer that I don't
think anybody can answer it but it's
clear it's very clear that you know
Jarrod golf's gonna have nightmares
about this game and again I'll say one
other thing
do not let Shaun McVeigh off the hook
and I think Shaun McVeigh is an
excellent young coach and for all these
people saying ah what a bum all this
stuff hey listen this guy took a
moribund franchise when he got there a
franchise that was one of the worst
three regardless of their record at the
time seven and nine it's one of the
worst four or five franchises in the
league in my opinion they're in LA
there's all this pressure to do well and
you look at this look at what Shaun
McVeigh accomplished to me I but having
said all that
where was the out-of-the-box thinking in
this game where were the the the plays
that you know that we're in the
laboratory for two weeks with Shaun
McVeigh and Zach Taylor there was no
explosion there was no
there are no like fun gimmicky type
things there is nothing on special teams
with John fossil I you know and again
I'm not killing these guys but I'm
saying that they should look go back and
look at what made them successful which
is double reverses jet sweeps and all I
mean they should go back and look at
those and say where were they in the
Superbowl those are the kind of
questions I'd be asking myself not just
putting it all on golf shoulders and we
spent time talking about that Peter what
Doug Peterson of the Eagles did last
year to come up with creative plays the
game-winning touchdown that you
chronicled so well after Super Bowl 5252
a play that they came up with it they
ensured it was a look it was a play the
Patriots had never seen before
I think McVeigh's biggest strength and
and this is a compliment is his ability
to call plays in the run-of-the-mill
play in and play out driving and drive
out grind of a game he has a good sense
of what's gonna work in a given spot but
you just can't show up with everything
you've ever done for Super Bowl 53
against Bill Belichick because he will
know everything you've ever done and he
will be ready to counter whatever it is
that you are going to do and I thought
the most telling nugget that came out of
the Super Bowl Peter was that and I
think CBS picked up on this during the
broadcast that the Rams were breaking
the huddle with 15 seconds or left on
the play clock to shut off Bill
Belichick's ability to communicate to
his defense willing to give up McVeigh's
ability to communicate with Jared Goff
thinking that all things equal it's
better to not have Belichick talking
than it is to have me talking to my
quarterback that tells me that at some
level the confidence wasn't there that
they were gonna be able to out smarting
out with Bill Belichick and I would say
this if this is the way you've been
running your offense for 35 games that's
how many games that that Shaun McVeigh
had coached this Rams team and one of
his trademarks is get to the line either
do that little sugar huddle where you
know you don't you're not in the huddle
for a long time maybe you just lean in
and get a quick
something and then and then what happens
is you get to the line of scrimmage and
you've got the voice in your ear you're
looking around you're checking this way
you're checking that way and then and
only then do you find out what you're
going to do with finality maybe with 21
20 19 seconds left on the play clock it
gives you time to communicate to your to
your offense and so I mean I would have
to really find out what exactly the
philosophy was on that so I'm not gonna
sit here and say was a horrible mistake
but if you've coached one way for 35
games and now you're coaching a
different way now I wonder what effect
if any that had on the performance of
Jared Golf and you know there's a
thought going forward that this
experience will help Sean McVeigh the
next time he's coaching a Super Bowl
team it'll help Jared golf if he's the
quarterback of the Rams if and when they
get back to a Super Bowl I can look at
this the other way though and say this
experience may have freaked them out
sufficiently may have scarred them
sufficiently that the next time around
they're gonna have a hard time pushing
out the bad memory and just kind of
going back to square one and doing it a
different way I just feel like there
wasn't enough time spent on creativity
and maybe both golf and McVeigh got a
little overwhelmed by the moment and we
should have expected that to a certain
extent and I think that Andrew Whitworth
made some comments after the game to
Mike silver confirming this idea that
that guys were just a little too
overwhelmed in the last team that's
going to be overwhelmed by a Super Bowl
is the team that's had its head coach
and its quarterback there nine times and
has been there four out of the last five
seasons
I always thought coming into this game
that that was gonna be a factor I never
in a hundred years thought that the Rams
would score three points and the only
three points would be scored on a almost
a Hail Mary field goal it was it was I
think it was an amazing performance by
the Patriots I also think as you say you
know Bill Parcells once said this a long
time ago that just when somebody asked
him what and in fact on that car ride
that I took was Sean McVeigh you know
one of the things that
you know I passed along to him on that
weekend Mike was something that Parcells
once said he said just remember it's a
freakin football game you know it's just
a football game and that you need at
some point to strip away everything and
you need to make this the regular
Saturday night meetings the regular game
all that other stuff that's what you
need to do and again time will tell how
the Rams handle this but experience is
usually the best teacher with this one
of the reasons why I think the Patriots
need to be giving so much credit over
there over the last 18 years if we go
back to that first Super Bowl remember
how John Madden was saying when the
Patriots had the ball inside the
two-minute warning Madden is saying
that's it that's it just bleed the clock
go to overtime play for overtime it's
1717 you're you're in great shape don't
just play for overtime well Brady and
Belichick is thought differently at the
time you know and they went and threw
those safe passes to the backs and
gotten positioned for Vinny Terry to
make the winning field goal before
overtime so the Patriots really have
never ever been blown away or adversely
affected by the pressure of the moment
but you're right Mike it appears that
the Rams were
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports